[Music]
well here we are in the Indian Ocean a
very remote part indeed of the Indian
Ocean we are 35 metres down that is four
hundred and forty two feet
take in the view I guess in the next
hour we'll explore an area of the ocean
which is uncharted undiscovered unknown
just above the Twilight Zone beneath us
off the coral atoll of Aldabra it is a
mission to discover new species to find
new life and to see if man's impact
stretches to this pristine and protected
part of the world well it is science it
is exploration it is adventure all
combined and has never been done before
on a live television program this is a
world first Aldabra is famous for its
remoteness and for its very treacherous
currents
anything could happen so don't go
anywhere sit back enjoy the views like
we are and let us take you down to the
depths very cozy in here getting warmer
by the minute I have to say and one
person that I'm already very well
acquainted with is my pilot for this
mission Randy holt thank you so much for
having us
and well what an extraordinary working
environment you have it's amazing down
here you know I every dive is different
and we get to go places where people
have never been before so explain where
we are going to change the cameras which
I can do we've tucked herself into a
crevice if we are 135 meters in yeah
we're kind of leaning against the edge
of a cliff an underwater cliff
we were fighting some down drafts and
some up drafts when we got to this
position so we just kind of perked
ourselves on a ledge and are trying to
stay stationary and I should give you a
proper title of course you are and
aquanauts if an astronaut explores space
you explore the deep yes you know where
an inner space it's a whole new place
down here and you know it's a 3d
environment so we're always moving
around because know where we are how how
we're moving through the water column
are we lighter are we done for heavier
all that it's it's it's amazing to watch
you with all the controls and as you
said you're flying these submersibles
you're not driving them and as you said
the oceans make up 97% of the habitable
space on planet Earth which gives you
both a sense of the depth of the oceans
but also that 3d environment that Randy
was talking about
we have adjoined an expedition led by
the scientists of the natural mission
their aim is to perform a deep ocean
health check to map to chart to sample
to see perhaps what no one has ever seen
before and
even search for those rarely seen
species lurking in the shadows the dream
perhaps of a sixgill shark or even a
Celia camp the Dino fish thought to be
extinct for millions of years and
crucially to see what is happening to
that often colourful coral as it faces
unprecedented threats it is so important
as habitat and home to millions of
species the big question for the
scientists is could the deeper ocean be
a refuge from the dangers of climate
change and even from plastic pollution
that we've talked so much about at sky
well we are not alone down here this is
some one the red one although it's been
showered by this downdraft of sediment
which you will hear the team referred to
as Omega out there we can see them is
sub to the yellow at the yellow one yes
the yellow one what we have the red one
I've already forgotten I wish they
called Kensington should we see if we
can raise them actually because in there
is the principal scientist on this
amazing expedition dr. Lucy Woodall from
the nectar mission and piloting her sub
is Robert Carmichael let's see if we can
raise them on the ship on the air so
yeah underwater telephone Kensington
Kensington Omega come back
[Laughter]
I'm gonna pass you off there now to
interview Lucy about the importance of
[Music]
try again try again hello Lucy can you
hear me
hello Lucy can you hear us I was just
asking you about the reasons you're
trying to explore the deep
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Thank You Lucy
I try and talk to you a little bit later
thank you so the scientists have been
coming down as I said very delicately
trying to take samples of some of the
deep puddles that we've seen some of
their the fans that are absolutely
beautiful certainly and they very
delicately take some of those and back
up to the surface and up on the surface
if we pair up we can see the outline of
the mothership above and up there is my
colleague Mark Austin mark we're up here
we're safe and well amazing I just can't
believe that we're seeing you and
hearing you like this just I mean just
give us a sense of how we feeling right
now
well it's well apart from being very hot
it's just quite extraordinary just
before we came on air we saw a white tip
shark very near help down there was it
to think random oh it was three meters
away three meters away from us you never
know quite what you're going to see all
above us it gets more and more blue down
beneath us it's like a murky brown color
it looks very very forbidding I have to
say and so the deep beneath us we
already went down there to about a
hundred and seventy five meters but
above it looked pleasantly light I can
see small fish dancing on this rocky
outcrop just above and obviously it's
nice to have the company of the
principal scientist Lucy Woodall so
great to be here mark but tell us a bit
about where we are and just off algebra
which I suppose is called the mothership
it's a it's a supply ship but right now
it's anything but a supply ship it's
sort of travelling up as first of all a
TV Operations Center I don't we can see
the guys working in the porter cabin
that's on this deck and they've got the
controls and they are the reason why
those pictures from you are getting to
us and then from us being satellited to
the viewer so big television operation
on this ship also the main reason how
the ship is here it's basically a marine
research scientific center and I think
also we can see now pictures of the
scientists hopefully in their in their
little laboratory here several little
laboratories here where they take
samples they analyze these samples and
they look at data and they take a lot of
the samples back to the UK so this ship
anythingg butter supply ship
right now Thomas More's with me you've
been looking at the pictures they're
from down below you've been here as well
for three weeks what do you make of what
you're seeing absolutely fantastic
Anna's saying there there's you seen a
white tip reef shark I imagine she will
see many many more I was walking through
the shallows with black tip reef sharks
yesterday
coming right up to my legs no harm from
them but there are many other sharks
down there she's going to have a
fantastic ride all right and back to you
but rest assured if we lose you I'm well
I don't mean lose you like that I mean
lose communications with you I'll be
here I'll be your backstop as if we
haven't heard enough about backstops but
let's go back down to Anna 137 meters
below Anna
yeah don't lose me mama please don't
lose me I think Brandis gonna take
charge of that thank goodness you're
here and the final thing to introduce is
the robotic camera down here I hope hear
us talk about the ROV the remotely
operated vehicle it is controlled at the
mothership where Mark is by highly
skilled pilots I have to say and there
are often lots of images of our
submersibles and beyond and is also
crucially the backstop of pictures as
well because it is tethered to the
surface unlike us down here for when our
signal drops out from this sub is
probably at will at some point it's real
very dependent on what the currents are
doing down here and the technology of
how we are communicating is completely
pioneering and very challenging so when
you do lose up as Mark said there to
expect that marvel I pick up back on the
ship and the ROV is not actually perhaps
we can give it away that seems there
behind us okay so Mike so I can't
Thomas it just a thing you can't can't
we and well mark showed you algebra so
let's just put that shall we in the
context of the Indian Ocean the necron
mission which is what we are part of is
happening in these Seychelles in the
western Indian Ocean the least explored
yet the most threatened of the world's
oceans and we're diving off our debris
and idyllic at all 700 miles southwest
of the main Seychelles island of maje
were actually though closer to Africa
some 400 miles away from others there
and around 270 miles northwest of
Madagascar the visibility here is
amazing and the sphere of perspex gives
us a 270 degree view you can look above
you can look even below where our feet
off and you can look left and right as
we do all the time you must be very
tempted to look around you all the time
oh yes there's so many things in fact if
you stay in one spot for 10 to 15
minutes you see something you never saw
before we can also control the cameras
down here as I said we are perched on a
rocky outcrop there it is recharging
whoa yeah try some lights
[Music]
there we are we are literally hanging on
to the seamount face the wall that
builds up to the at all if you imagine
this was an old mountain that has
gradually sung to leave this enormous
Lagoon in the middle of it you can fit
there sizably fit Manhattan in New York
in the middle of the lagoon above us and
that's partly why we have such
difficulty
with the currents because at certain
times of the day all the water floods
out and all the water floods in think
it's time for a safety check regular
safety checks down here the service
topside topside Omega our current depth
is four for three feet our heading is
one Niner zero degrees like core systems
are good
[Music]
a primitive leg out well we have to do
that every 15 minutes so that top side
as the submersible safety officer is
called can regularly keep in touch with
where we are and that was very important
as we descended wasn't it yeah we do
regular communications checks with the
surface part of that is a safety at that
lose comms with us we have a set
procedure we go through and eventually
we'll go to the surface if you have a
pregame absolutely and normally you'd be
mapping the reef wouldn't you as you
descend to try and check a transept a
video for the scientists above and give
them information when they go back to
wherever they're going they're from all
over the world aren't there the
scientists up there and a reminder too
that we really don't know what is
beneath 'less no one have got what
puffed nuts this morning has ever been
deeper than where we are and we don't
know where what we're going to see where
would we're going to shift direction
suddenly now what is very important to
remember here is that there are a number
of zones people used to think that it
was just the shallows and then they
would think it was the depths and now
gradually they're realizing that there
are many stages in between the zones are
changing so for example you get the
scuba zone which is not 230 perhaps 40
if you're very experienced here it would
probably be naught to 20 meters because
there is no decompression unit here
very difficult to get help so most
people diving here if they're allowed
you have to have very careful permits
would only get to 20 meters the first of
these zones then where the scuba divers
go is called the alte photic zone known
as the sunlit zone enough light
penetrates this upper layer of water for
reef-building calls to thrive it's also
the most exposed to the impacts of human
activity so the mixed own down which is
where we are now is the Misa photic zone
40 meters to about a hundred and fifty
meters the middle light zone it's called
often regarded as the start of the
twilight zone at this level sunlight
starts to dwindle corals become flatter
and thinner they are more likely to be
plankton eaters than use the
photosynthesis at the algae inside them
and here you begin to see the white tip
reef sharks which I mentioned we saw
just before we came on air you're more
likely to see the potato groupers and
I'm liberal it makes mostly some of
those as well and you might see that
this is perhaps a refuge from some of
those dangers that I mentioned
next is a new zone that people have
found they thought beneath us the life
would tail away with his very little
light from the surface and it became
increasingly difficult to see life
beneath us but now confirmed in a
previous negative omission in fact there
is the rarey photic zone 150 meters down
to 300 meters the term that scientists
use to describe rare amounts of like
rare fo take it our mission on the whole
of this week's coverage in deep ocean
live is to get to the bottom end of this
zone to 300 meters the zone largely
unexplored unlikely there are maybe
thousands of marine creatures down there
that have never really been seen before
300 meters is the maximum that this
submarine can dive to we don't want to
do that but they are designed and
pressure tested with some safety factors
in there so it's actually been tested
beyond 300 meters
okay well let's talk now to our science
correspondent Thomas Moore who has dug
deeper at a very different Island in
Alfonse and understands these zones and
the importance of them to science Thomas
that perhaps you get the biggest or the
greatest biomass up in the shallows but
down here you start to see the sort of
diversity that might provide all sorts
of answers to life on Earth yeah
absolutely and I mean it the textbooks
would say that the greatest biodiversity
the greatest number of fish and marine
species would be in the shallows in that
sunlit zone but I think the more people
do explore the deeper ocean the more
their understanding that there is an
awful lot of life down there perhaps
more life than the reason the shallows
in fact and that is the threat that
commercial fisheries are now attracted
to the mezzo photic layer where you are
where you get very rich fish numbers and
those could be trawled in future before
scientists have really been given a
chance to understand what lives down
there tens of thousands of marine
species still need to be discovered down
there and what you're seeing around you
is quite exquisite you're seeing sea
fans you're seeing sea whips are the
forms of soft corals and all around you
it's snowing Anna that is marine snow
that is coming down from the sunlit
layer debris bits of food the other fish
have left over and that is gonna fall
all the way to the sea bottom but this
much of it we snapped up by life below
so it is quite an extraordinary scene
that you are witness to
and if you went even deeper Thomas
Trivedi perhaps he even beyond that to
the abyss the difficulty for life down
there is lack of oxygen very small
amounts of oxygen no food as you say the
stuff that's coming down will be gobbled
up as it as it descends deeper no
sunlight almost zero sunlight and of
course constant pressure this extreme
pressure and low temperatures it's very
difficult isn't it for life to exist as
we go deeper and deeper into the ocean
and I said I lost you slightly there
with the communications but I think
you're talking about the importance of
lights to the ocean and it drives
everything on the sunlight zone you've
got lots of corals which form these
reefs different corals will grow at
different rates some can grow at 25
centimeters a year others perhaps just a
few millimeters but down where you are
although you can still get reef-building
corals because there's so little light
they tend to change their shape so
you'll get the same kind of coral same
species of coral but it takes on a much
flatter shape and a table coral it's
called just to try and maximize the
amount of sunlight but the algae inside
that turned that light into energy and
feed the coral polyps what are you
seeing down there Anna
what are we seeing down here we're
seeing very small fish you'd think
perhaps they were more like small marine
fish Thomas we're seeing a large number
of sea fans some a little bit difficult
to see in this image way of presenting
to you now but we will move around very
shortly we're seeing some with coral a
lot of thin lines and they're famous
because they can't retract their
tentacles if you imagine that coral is a
food for large numbers of animals most
corals try to whip in their tentacles
certainly to get out of the way and
parrotfish famously are they bite
through coral with a fused front teeth
and that is in fact what gives us our
beautiful sandy beaches and some of this
debris we've had drop down I mean this
red submersible is completely covered in
that marine snow isn't it so at that is
probably washed away from the coral at
all and drops down on us has been quite
amazing actually
there the submersible
there it is it's here okay so we've got
the Yellow Submarine moving in now and
you've got a grabber arm on that haven't
you what to use that for to two purposes
in this mission we're using it to
collect samples for the scientists so
they identify certain species that are
indicative of the area that we're
exploring and we collect the samples in
which they process in the lab later the
other reason is for self-rescue okay in
what way if we were to become entangled
we can cut a line or free up another
submersible or earlier in the mission we
can attach a recovery line to equipment
that might found a sequel has that ever
happened to you yes not getting
entangled but recovering well I'm glad
I'm glad to hear that's not gonna happen
to you certainly it's absolutely
fascinating down here I have to say that
when we started this journey the
submersible tips down forward like that
it's quite amazing so it tips down and
then we drop into all it almost a hole
of light and you look back and it's as
if the surface is a mirror image it's
like we should be jumping into it and
not the other way around and then what
has surprised me is that you descend
through balloon it's just you it's the
open seas they describe it as the desert
of the oceans I was expecting to see
fish straight away but is this strange
solitary feeling when you're dropping
down
did you get that still or not every time
it is exciting yet once you leave the
surface and even if there's waves and
that action like you described in the
different layers once you're underwater
it's smooth and then you're just looking
for the bottom and you know as you get
closer to that that sea floor that's
when all the life stuff starts to come
by and check you out yes and certainly
we've had the little fish as soon as we
landed on what was a sandy bottom we
have the little fish dancing around us
to the sea and then here because it's
such a steep sided underwater mountain
what did you do then well we had a lot
of downdraft and a lot of updraft so we
were kind of finding different areas
getting out of out of the current and
and we came in here to this rock we
found this this neat feature little cave
in front of us and we're just kind of
hunkered in there and and I actually
grabbed onto the rock to try to remain
stable yes and that was partly
that was partly wasn't it to try and
save battery how much battery do you
actually have we have quite a bit if
we're maneuvering a lot and using a lot
of thrusters it could be reduced to two
or three hours if we do a lot of time
exploring and just kind of drifting with
the currents that are there we can stay
down for about six hours and if
something went wrong darrel ions if
something went wrong we have a lot of
methods to deal with that the emergency
is to come to the surface but if we were
to become stuck on the bottom and we
have 96 hours of emergency life support
four days four days and how would you be
rescued somewhere like this 135 metres
down well fortunately we have two other
tools are on the mission we have ii
submersible same def capabilities and
another arm on that so they can come
investigate the entanglement they can
hook up a recovery line they can try to
have us the news of whatever we're in we
also have two ROV which I believe can go
up to 500 meters in it as well as a
little grabber arm
[Music]
and in fact you can see the grabber arm
on the front of the ROV certainly that
allows it to get into a cage and so the
little thing you can see at the bottom
front of your screen that is the grabber
arm of the the ROV and that gets into
the cage that then is raised in the
surface to get out of the way see looks
like a syllabus of coral stuck to the
top of it isn't it now where is that
where's the other submersible goal I
can't quite see it I don't feel mean how
do you see them where are they
interesting
behind us that's all around
see their lights anywhere no there might
be just below us a little bit I have to
say that we descend separately don't we
and then we meet up below us
no can't quite see them both no again
but it's very difficult sometimes in the
gloomy lie to try and meet up isn't it
it's quite difficult to to meet up under
the water it is in fact today we
descended together which makes a little
easier stay together but we do have the
tracking system on the ship so they have
the ability to know what the position of
each sub is and how to get us together
it's worth pointing out at this point I
guess that I am in fact the copilot
that's true
I can't find the other submarine that's
probably our submersible rather which is
one of the things I'm supposed to do
isn't it if anything happens to you then
I would have to take over yeah that's
correct if I was to pass out for some
reason it's actually very simple to
bring the submarine to the surface
there's two valves you open up and the
air will start to go into our main
ballast tanks and you're on the way to
the surface and we use the the sub radio
don'twe they would you know what you
pretend called an underwater tahoe
Jennifer yeah and you can talk to the
surfaces through water columns it's a
hydrophone and the surface officer has
that list of emergency procedures to
talk with you as well okay and I would
say
pilot asleep put on is that a nice way
to put it seems to be how you'll
practice again yeah leave I'm bringing
the summary and he fell asleep co-pilot
ready to ascend would you mind if it was
an emergency
you'd once the x-ray x-ray x-ray okay
and they would know to do something up
there would they
yeah they know to freeze all the marine
traffic all of those they prepare for
the sub to come to the surface and come
up quickly what are the elements that
you need to keep an eye on when you're
talking to the surface safety officer
you've got depth pressure temperature
all of these things why are they
important in life it's important to give
a consistent report as you can hear what
the columns sometimes they go in and out
so having that that study report of what
depth are we what direction are we
heading and our life-support systems
still on and
so we do those checks every 15 minutes
trying to see where they are can see
some light where are they they're below
us I think underneath us let's look
under our feet maybe they're under us no
can't see you
when I went to a left yeah they're still
on our body
below us and the importance of pressure
obviously it's it's absolutely critical
isn't it if you go a thousand meters
it's a hundred times the pressure 300
meters 30 times the pressure so if we
accidentally got out of this right now
what would happen to us well they're
sold as he mentioned the pressure
there's so much force on every little
you know square centimeter of that hatch
in fact if we were to undock the hatch
you couldn't even open it every one of
us putting your shoulder into it okay
well that's amazing isn't it Emily and
the other submersible is down believes
us now a little bit earlier certainly we
had a visitor we were moving up slightly
and there was a potato grouper who
decided to come and say hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they're nosy animals why do you think
they come and find us
you know we're aliens in their
environment so they come and they check
us out and I think they're just curious
when he followed us up for what 200
feets do you think how much is that
about 70 meters he decided to rise to
the surface more yeah I saw him first
down beneath the sudden anything I came
up and was exploring and getting right
up against the spirit absolutely
brilliant now we were talking about
pressure temperature and every
the need to be you know as you said you
could push this up well I do have all
these dials behind you because you also
have a digital display as well
yeah the digital display controls some
of the lights but it's mostly for
convenience a navigation for the pilot
there's a lot of redundancy in the
submersible so we do have analog gauges
and a valve to be able to shut down any
particular part of any of the systems so
just from the top the green is the
oxygen that's part of our life support
and we are bringing pure oxygen into the
cabin at the same rate that we catalyze
it to keep it at that normal level the
black is the new ballast air that we use
to distribute to the ballast systems
that allows us to control our buoyancy
underwater telephone you saw and then
down the panel is the electrical
and the only way to feel the true
temperature and this is getting really
wet up here as many is to feel this and
then you suddenly feel actually yeah it
was quite cool cuz the rest of it feels
really hot because it's such an enclosed
environment yeah our acrylic sphere that
we're in while it's great visibility
it's a big insulator right so this this
aluminium patch we can feel directly
with the water temperature I'm gonna
draw yourself actually drips my
rainwater doesn't know that condensation
is good that means the life-support
system is working okay okay well I'll
leave it up its do provide and you do
constantly dry ourselves off you don't
really want waster in here when we're
getting in at the surface you're very
careful not to let water get in like
yeah I can't affect the performance of
the scrubber and obviously electronics
don't like seawater and each of the
submersibles have slightly different
scientific tasks to perform don't know
easy so what what is yours I mean that
moment will knocked on see I'm not sure
you can quite see it but we're locked on
just beneath that shot by your brother
on rakhi service
yeah the Omega has been set up for this
mission as what we're calling the
sampling stuff so we with the arm we're
collecting samples at the direction of
the scientists we also have
water collection system to sample water
different depths as well as the CTD
which is monitoring the conductivity
temperature and depth throughout our
dive and then the camera with the feed
that you're seeing that's our HD camera
that allows us to actually film certain
specimens in detail
and I'm in the red sub here we've got
Lucy and Robert in the yellow sub the
different jobs as USA if we put our
lights on even more committee that we
let out her and everything and then you
can spot us
and is that helpful when you get even
deeper and an even darker yeah you know
we navigate with the lights off a lot of
the time because of the deep blues it's
easier to see distance but once we get
close to something we'll put on a lot of
light and that brings the color back
into what we're seeing it makes it
easier to identify the species and
different things that were looking at
fantastic well and all of those elements
as we mentioned earlier are taken up to
the surface where there are all sorts of
scientists at work right now Mark Austin
is there
and thank you very much Anna we take so
much of this for granted don't we
communications and on loud with GPS and
satellites but of course all of that
doesn't really work underwater so it's
worth explaining perhaps how we are how
we are doing this and it is that we've
got the two subs below us now at 120
hundred and thirty meters below the ship
and at that level you know salt and
pressure and the lack of electromagnetic
waves means that that the traditional TV
signal does not get through so a
receiver has been lowered to between the
subs and a where we are in fact so the
subs then use LED lights LED lights are
transmitting the beams up to the
receiver audio and visual signals and
then it's transferred by cable to the
ship where we are and from here our
satellite be a normal traditional
television communication means satellite
gets the picture to you well I'm joined
by Oliver steed who's the head of the
mission thanks very much for joining us
I mean this seeing pictures like this
live pictures like this has been a bit
of a mission of yours and a dream of
yours it has it's been a true you and I
think that's because there's two stories
in the world about the ocean one is a
negative one and we know what's
happening to our ocean we're
sleepwalking into a disaster at the
moment and there's the other side which
is just how wonderful our ocean is you
know this is the blue planet and the
beating heart of our planet is our ocean
and we need people to fall in love with
it we need to inspire people and it
and I hope pictures like this can do
that because if we can do that if people
can fall in love with the ocean there's
a hope that want to look after it and if
they would look after a baby the
politicians will be given a mandate to
act and act a lot faster than they need
then they are at the moment
yeah look we could have done this anyway
why Aldabra i mean obviously it's a very
special place but why out there and why
why now so algebra is the Galapagus of
the Indian Ocean but there's first
there's been no research believe 30
meters here so we need to understand how
the ocean is changing particularly
Indian Ocean which is the least explored
and one of the most one of the most
unprotected oceans on the planet so what
we're here to do is to try and gather
that action that actionable data
undertake a series of first descents and
use that data to help inform the
Seychelles government particularly about
their commitment to protect 30% of the
ocean by 2020 that's an area about twice
the size of the entire UK yeah I mean
it's protected Haven in many ways but
you've been here we may be seeing the
signs of damage from climate change of
pollution we are yes we Don on the
actual island itself and our divers will
see tomorrow as well plastic was washing
out there we're also experiencing an El
Nino in these parts as well the warming
ocean the antigenic heat that we
produced is now going into the ocean
warming it out the impact on the coral
so supportin times try to establish a
baseline and those stems to see how that
ocean changing how that's going to
affect the lives and livelihoods of
turnoff billion people deliver the
nation's around the Indian Ocean
thanks very much indeed and it just
extraordinary getting this television
signal from Dowell and where Anna is an
anime even have a spot of news for you
down there
[Music]
I can't tell whether you finished I do
apologize it's quite muddy sound down
here
now we promised you a news bulletin from
the deep from 135 meters down here we go
then and there is no um apologizing for
this no escaping bricks if news even
down here our top stories here on Sky
News and Theresa May will hold more
talks with DUP MPs and her own
backbenchers as she tries to gather
support for her brexit deal the
government has said there will be no
vote in the House of Commons if it looks
likely to lose to New Zealand now and
the cabinet has backed gun war changes
in principle after the Christchurch
shootings it follows the deaths of 50
people at two mosques on Friday
and there are calls for addiction to
social media to be classed as a disease
a new report by LPS wants more
regulation to protect children from
firms which they say are operating in an
online Wild West well that is your news
from the deep I'm pretty sure that no
one has done that before so there you go
another world first I think we did
another safety check don't wait topside
topside Omega
Omega reporting deaf four four four feet
heading 1 9 0 degrees stationery life
support is good
[Music]
[Music]
good copy
well don't forget if you want to get
involved in this and they people really
want you to because in showing the
oceans like this with the remote
operating vehicle air coming both of
these submersibles they really want
people to see what the ocean is like do
get in touch using hashtag a deep ocean
life and as well as being on Sky News
and on Sky Atlantic
we're also on YouTube as well so
fantastic way of getting involved also
reminder too that on Wednesday we will
be doing a question and answer session
from the deep if you have any questions
please do tweet us hashtag deep ocean
live and if you've done anything to pass
on plastic hashed I pass on plastic is
the way to let us know about that now
can we talk to the yellow sub let's try
hello Robert and Lucy can you hear us
[Music]
oh by the underwater telephone right
let's try that Kensington Kensington
Omega copied at four six nine on our
starboard side
[Music]
hello Lucy this is such an exciting
mission for you isn't it to be the first
team ever to go deep off Aldabra atoll
it must be an amazing feeling for all of
you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what have you seen so far to make you
excited about the deep what have you
seen so far down here to make you
excited that this is a healthy
environment for marine animals
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
is that because they are plankton
feeders rather than leading the light
from photosynthesis from algae that live
amongst them and if there was one
creature that you would really like to
see down here for yourself Lucy what
might it be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Lucy thank you so much for the moment
thank you well we've certainly been
looking out for that barnacle there we
go we'll turn that down so we can hear
ourselves let's just remind you of the
journey down here to 135 meters as I
said this submersible tips forward
doesn't it tips right forward you start
entering the ocean and you drop down
through almost a circle of light as you
come down dropping down through the blue
of the ocean brighter blue even debt
down here certainly until you get to the
bottom and you're met with perhaps some
fish if you're lucky if not and
certainly earlier we were met with a
dancing array of small fish
extraordinary journey down as a novice
like me but I know you're probably a
little bit more used to it every dive is
exciting though around here it's a place
I've never gone before the life is
different and so
it's always mean I think we're gonna
move soon I'm just gonna remind people
that the technology is extremely
difficult we're trying to transmit
pictures and sound using light beams
through water it's extremely difficult
so shall we it'll take a bit of time I'm
gonna let you just get ready to do that
it's gonna take a couple of minutes for
us to get ready to go all right just
turn a couple systems back
first one being the air conditioner so
we can see
Kensington Omega
[Applause]
just confirming you're clear we're gonna
maneuver out of this location
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah coffee right behind us four five
six
[Applause]
[Applause]
negative unlights to stay just don't
come behind us
[Applause]
so just as you know that the postman
the grabber arm turn out did you can see
any of the deadly femoral papers in
there
holding us to the moche surface will be
harder particularly
[Applause]
[Music]
to make sure
[Applause]
where's your song
[Music]
beautiful water
[Music]
I look up I can see the top of the rock
the outcome
[Applause]
[Music]
get out
the smoke me out Bob
and you see probably the driver
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're just moving
[Music]
the best way to describe it
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this here
Shailja beautiful
you see for my papers no
they've been taking
[Music]
[Music]
alone 200 meters so it's very strictly
controlled the samples that the
scientists
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
which is fantastic desires
[Music]
yeah one of the things they've been
asking us to do for eclectic
and filming
when it insisted because the ones
[Applause]
and Thomas this is such an exciting
moment or always to be moving around in
the submersible
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Thomas I know everyone on deck is
that's what the losers
creatures that we see down here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we seem to describe difficulties
[Applause]
[Music]
is behind us
[Music]
see underwater mountain Wars
and explain to the surface the small
[Music]
[Applause]
Regine communication shall we with
Thomas More on the surface Thomas I have
to say we can
privileged to see a number of shots on
our Burien side
[Applause]
on the mothership you're very lucky to
have seen that shark it's impossible to
tell from this distance what it was but
I can tell you that there are an awful
lot down there with you it's a sign of a
healthy reef sharks are what are known
as apex predators are not the only ones
down there there are groupers too that
are big consumers of smaller fish on the
reef why are the same many well because
this is at the middle of a really
strictly enforced marine protected area
what you're seeing there is evidence
that it works that these fish are given
a chance to grow to an enormous size
that there are plenty that there is
plenty of food for them to eat and
that's why the epic striated Predators
will thrive it is a lesson to other
areas of the world that marine
protection can lead to quite
extraordinary marine life and that's the
benefit for them and indeed for us as we
watch these pictures
Thomas they're said to be about 19
species of shark
[Music]
especially
[Music]
species
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and is now beneath us once again as we
just
we can see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
never
just to remind you this
we have a team who've been the deepest
ever in this part of the world
that if you are a scuba diver and go to
30 meters
around here perhaps only 20 meters
because it is so
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
I'm 35
[Music]
there's a lot of caves here and a lot of
places
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and sponges it's a bit like corals as
well they are animals
and certainly looks like
[Music]
[Applause]
500 million years ago today
[Music]
our sponge
[Music]
this mission
very confident
[Music]
see
to check image
[Music]
we move along
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well there are wardens who are based on
algebra over there
one of them who is now joined the nekton
mission
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a bit about those waters that
we're looking at right now she is from
the Seychelles and she was actually the
first Seychellois to take a dive like
Ana botting has now taken what do you
make of what you're seeing just
unbelievable because for someone who's
been here for two years you will never
actually imagine that this place is like
deep down there is like so beautiful so
much environment that you didn't expect
it to be like back down there in the
deep ocean is like so beautiful so
amazing yeah it's unbelievable how many
yeah and how I mean you went down the
other day what was it like being the
first person from the Seychelles to
descend to the depths like this it was
just amazing the feeling was it was
mixed feelings it was just for the first
time to ever be able to go down from
like a scuba lower than that the scuba
ft was like just breathtaking beautiful
and it's just incredible to see such
things it was so calm so like you see
fish is like just amazing
yeah now you spent two years on Aldabra
very briefly just sum up what that
island means to you just very quickly
someone
in came a home for two years it became a
place that every day you woke up you
wake you see the same place but it just
it was something always do something new
you always experience a new thing every
day was not it was the same they are the
new day yes but there was always
something new happen if there was always
that you go diving you always see
something different even if you are
going the same spot but yeah it's just
been a lovely place place that is close
to my heart all right well Stephanie
thanks very much you've just got a few
minutes left of this extraordinary hour
so let's go back down to Ana somewhere
down in the deep mark thanks very much
indeed down in the deep but looking up
actually and a shark that is still been
circling I don't know if the ROV can see
those pictures it's quite murky for us
to see we can't identify what type it is
but fantastic to see the shark above us
investigating and if we look above our
head there all these tiny fish that are
just watching us from above it's
absolutely wonderful to
and in front of us of course the Yellow
Submarine with the Robert and with Lucy
who are still investigating all the
nooks and the crannies as we have been
wonderful to try and hear inside after
all the creatures that might be living
there who knows some of them may never
have been seen and already we know that
carl's are used in cancer care like
prostaglandin and so there's still so
much to investigate that may be used for
Humanity that's why they need to be
investigated that's why the scientists
reelecting mission are on this ship
trying to look more deeply at what is
under what is in the deep ocean and what
they can see I'm going to show you the
yellow submarine again there it is the
lights against the wall you can see how
steep it is that it rises from the deep
that the thermal currents that will
farmer pliers that whip around these
areas that's the difference is there
between temperature in the ocean layer
of the different layers
[Music]
we're floatin you don't even need the
thrusters on the currents are good we're
just about stuttering thank you so much
for watching us here thank you so much
to Randy for taking us through in your
world it's an extraordinary place to be
I have to say that's pretty much all we
have time for tomorrow hopefully mark
will be down perhaps going deeper will
assess perhaps the plastics that we see
here and also on the island of Aldabra
plenty more from us down in the deep on
deep ocean live thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes welcome to the Indian Ocean where we
have just stopped where we witnessed a
broadcasting first because about a
couple hundred metres below me has been
my colleague Anna bossing for the last
hour I hope you've been watching our the
first ever live television broadcast
from under the ocean and those are the
pictures that we've been looking at this
is a live picture now and we've been
looking at some wonderful pictures and I
hope that Anna body now aware that she's
got to come up because they've been down
for some time now but I hope that Anna
can hear me because I want to ask her
and be the first to ask her what that
experience was like Anna I hope you can
hear me still well it is entirely about
broadly mark that's the only way I can
describe it we just turned our air
conditioning off so you can hear it
better so we'll start to probably fill
back in here quite quickly and in fact
this starts dripping rain on us as such
as the condensation in this small
perspex fear that we're in it is
entirely otherworldly if I just changed
my camera you can see what it looks like
that is the other sub as submersible
the yellow submersible with the
principal scientist in it Lucy would
rule and the pilot Robert Carmichael
we've also been down here a little bit
deeper epic now aren't we
488 488 feet down such about 140 Connor
was sinking slightly in moments we can
get a little bit
Neeraj of the the yellow submersible as
we see and we can see them in there
perhaps they can wave to us
no they're looking because we have just
identified some cold that we've not seen
certainly down here there Lucy's looking
around just wonderful but it really is
otherworldly that's the only way to
describe it first of all we've had a
shark circling around us for most of the
program when you look up it's a
beautiful blue color but when you look
below it is a murky it's not blue it's
not deep blue as I was expecting it to
be but certainly here because the
legality of Aldabra flushes out there is
a lot of sediment that falls or perhaps
that's why you get a sense of it being a
brown and other world is we can't show
what it looks like down that's partly
because we're right by this rock face I
have to say it doesn't give us quite so
much maneuverability and this really
shows the geography of this call at all
right in the middle of the Indian Ocean
it is
previous mountain is called a seam up
now what would have happened is that the
mountain itself would have begun to fall
on descend and to drop leaving behind
the coal that it made its home and
certainly what they were expecting to
see here is coral at different levels of
depth and previous uncleanness ice ages
were then a flooded post ice ages would
have flooded and the sea levels would
have risen and we're a little bit
further out I think that the mirror is
currently flat now yes so we're seeing
the old world mountains to the ancient
the ancient mountain side here and the
colors that have made this place their
home the small fish - are you surprised
grandi by how many fish you see at a
depth like this you know not I'm not
super surprised what what intrigues me
is that a lot of these you expect to see
in a shallow reef then we go deeper and
they're down here
it's
amazing what life is where we've never
been and done
and these are extraordinary aren't they
look at these beautiful the light of our
camera picking out just beautiful yellow
and presuming it's a Karl I don't know
we've seen sponges as well haven't we
and what is important to remember is
that these are living animals and need
to look like the other
like their clothes these are living
creatures that are probably on this rock
face in order to catch the plankton and
is swirling around the ocean and is
brought up from the
as we move along with different colors
and the from the the white light of the
beach almost that has come down as
Marine snow absolutely beautiful see
these things that we've never seen
before
[Music]
[Music]
and just above us all the fish the
different sized fish that come to see us
and swimming in front the swimming above
[Music]
what we're going to do now isn't gonna
have to start ascending we've nearly got
to the end of our battery life have who
do you think we need the power to take
us to the surface what will happen is
that you will eventually lose
communications with us I don't know if
the remote camera can see the lights
above us I can't quite see it now that
is a depressor connected to the ship and
we are being a light to that and that's
how we are managing to communicators
have to come really quite close to us
today to try and see if we could get
communication with the other submersible
that will have to be pulled out of the
way and as soon as that is Darwin then
you will lose communications with us but
the remotely operated vehicle over there
the remote camera which has been piloted
from the ship's surface well hopefully
follow us are all the way to the surface
we currently that is
478 137 meters so you are hopefully
follow us up as far as you can from a
hundred and thirty seven meters down all
the way to the surface and we'll see you
then part two leave a mark see you
shortly
[Laughter]
[Music]
we'll hopefully see before this hour is
out back on the surface I mean it has
been quite a spectacle being able to see
Anna
so clearly Thomas for our science
correspondent here see her so clearly
and here I'm not quite so clearly but at
least we did we did here what did you I
mean did you think that would be what we
saw I mean did you think we could do it
first of all it was a challenge
definitely I think the currents around
here have been extremely unpredictable
as they are around many of these
enormous underwater mountains around a
hundred thousand of those dotted around
the world but only a few dozen have been
explored and we are the first to explore
the seamount here in algebra but they do
whisk these currents around because all
that deep water is pushed up the side of
the mountain it can cause an
unpredictable current and also cause
there was this enormous Lagoon in the
center of here big enough to swallow up
Manhattan
you're quite comfortably all that water
nearly all of that water will come out
at low time spread around the island
that too makes the extremely challenging
intensity yeah I should just explain to
viewers where we are we're on a a supply
ship and offshore supply ship and we're
just about what four or five hundred
meters off the off the island it's
actually on this side you can see it and
tantalising because not many people can
go there you did you manage to stay the
night there with the local Rangers who
are working on the island just a few of
them but he said it's a it's a an island
that's been protected from man by man
hasn't it yeah absolutely emphatic so
station run by Seychelles Islands
foundation they have a team there who
safeguard the wildlife there it is
something which is where nature is is in
charge not not humans although sadly you
do see the effect of humans here in
terms of climate change so you will see
some bleaching of the coral here when
the coral spits out the algae that it
has inside which it depends on for
energy but what's remarkable and this is
what I found yesterday there is some
research on the island which shows that
the coral here recovers much more
quickly from these episodes and rather
than dying which were happening sadly
elsewhere in the Seychelles it seems to
be much more robust and that if they
think he is possibly because we are
surrounded by this marine protected area
there is no commercial fishing so there
are plenty of herbivorous fish chomping
away at the algae that would otherwise
swallow up the reef that is crucial for
what we see here in terms of fish life
and the cold absolutely and what we
can't see from
pictures that is Aldabra but beyond that
sort of reef there's because it's the
second largest coral reef coral atoll in
the world beyond that is this massive
Lagoon what 16 miles by 5 miles or
something which is the very central life
of that at all and the water rushes
through the inlet on the toll free with
it all sorts of wonderful marine life
yeah that's right an awful lot of
sediment and sediment equals nutrients
and where you've got nutrients you will
find an awful lot of life starting from
the very small and of course attracting
the very big and this area does have a
phenomenal number of apex predators
these are animals which are the top of
the food chain so thinking of sharks you
think your groupers and they're much
larger than they would be elsewhere and
in much greater numbers just because the
waters here are so rich let's just
explain what we're seeing I mean these
are pictures taken now from our remotely
operated camera being operated from just
across the ship across the deck here and
we are watching the submarine
submersibles ascending coming back and
and surely hopefully they will be back
on the surface and Anna will be back
with us but that that camera you can see
just the front of it that camera is is
what we're relying on at the moment for
these pictures yes indeed
now that is the the claw that remote
operated submersible users of course to
take submersibles and so on they were
seen in the foreground there but that is
one of these submersibles rising to the
surface they do like to take their time
they don't like to rush it they couldn't
in an emergency come up in in ten meters
from great depth to ten minutes rather
but they do for the comfort of everybody
on board like to come up a little more
slowly yeah now had we time during the
previous out we were going to talk a
little bit about what you've seen over
the last well three weeks you've been on
this boat just tell us a little about a
little bit about what you've seen I in
hammerhead sharks yes Andres I had all
thumps which was the first island group
that I visited and I went down in one of
the submersibles two to 200 meters and
yes I did see an awful lot of life there
I saw corals of course but also a
hammerhead shark and I barely had time
to get my my camera out before this
hammerhead was right on me is something
that I've always wanted to see this
extraordinary sharks with that great
classic shape of the hammer at the front
and it's got eyes on the end and it also
seems to have methods of detecting the
Rays buried in the sand there in his
head too and it gives it the almost
stereoscopic ability to pinpoint the Ray
and snaffle a while it's there they're
very clever they can apparently detect
the heartbeat fish hiding in the sand
yeah I see the right and then sharks do
have this disability with their with the
lateral lines and also sensors in their
in their heads do that they're able to
almost have that sixth sense they've got
very good vision good hearing to the
spell of course as we know and also this
ability google raise useful eagle rays -
beautiful beautiful creatures a metre
and a half across and of course it's
their their fins which have become
extended and developed into wings almost
and they they fly almost like birds
information under the water and they -
and attract other fish to them hoping to
pick off the scraps as they feed on some
fish now I've never seen a sunfish yeah
pretty big from a picture size yeah
savvy I wasn't the one to see this
you'll be talking to the scientists
shortly who did for the sunfish who did
see that was blown away because it is so
rare to see these things particularly
under the water you do see them popping
around on the surface with their very
high dorsal fins they're sometimes
mistaken for sharks but it was quite an
amazing thing just just to be swimming
very slowly past the submersible really
entering there well
and before we just came out here
everybody was talking about the
coelacanth I went to a laboratory in
Oxford where they were talking about the
coelacanth which was a well as a living
fossil of a fish tell us about the
silica so the coelacanth was thought to
be extinct they thought it died out
sixty-eight million years ago but last
century a few hundred miles to the South
here down the South Africa the
Mozambique Channel fishermen pulled up a
coelacanth in its in its net and they
immediately thought that this was a hoax
that it could not possibly be true and
yet we have Dino fish that living fossil
now possibly in these waters the kind of
environment we have here in algebra is
very like the environment where we have
now seen living examples of the
coelacanth this is such a strange fish
it is the only one to have a three lobes
tail it is the only one to have the
beginnings of legs terrestrial animal
legs in its fins and the beginnings
perhaps of lungs - it's such an unusual
fish we don't really understand where it
lives we don't understand where it fits
in to the family tree of life but it's
there I mean is there a chance of them
finding new species do you think most of
on this trip almost undoubtedly mark the
more you explore the deep the more you
find is probable that there are tens of
thousands of marine species yet to be
discovered
these are unexplored waters and as you
go deeper you will find more you'll find
corals you'll find fish your fee you'll
find other species too and really just
the work
doing here on the nekton ship is
beginning to catalogue that life for the
Seychelles government you and just there
finally on this now you may put a baited
camera down a common thing to do it's a
great great way of seeing marine life
undisturbed by humans safer if a
submersible or indeed with scuba diver
goes down there with a camera you're of
course going to get the interaction
between that human being and whatever
they're saying but if you put a baited
camera down there you are drawing in
marine life they build they smell
they're the churned fish guts in the in
there in the bait and it will come in
and you can capture that on camera we've
seen sharks we've seen groupers it is
quite an extraordinary sight yeah and
the pictures we're seeing now from under
but in the depth are as I was saying
from the remote control it looks as
though the submarines oh no that one of
the submarines is still there
submersibles is soon you can just see
how steep that wall is mark that's the
the underwater mountain we've been
talking about that rises four or five
thousand meters from the floor of the
Indian Ocean extremely steeply and we
don't really know what's going on under
the water because the last time this was
plumbed with with lead weights and rope
was 1800s and really we're only now
beginning to understand as we put out
survey ships with proper sonar equipment
look you'll get a much better idea of
the shape of the seafloor around here
and algebra
yeah okay wonderful pictures there and
thanks Thomas for the time being and
there's the mothership waiting now for
the return welcome an apostle really
wishing for the turn return of the
submersible that brought you those
wonderful pictures for the for the last
hour and what you can see there is very
interesting this is the depressor Nick
always a receiver really and this is the
bit of equipment that got you those
pictures this is the bit of equipment
that the the LED lights from the
submersibles has to hit so that the
receiver or depressor they call it can
then relay the pictures by cable to this
ship where we are and that is good news
because that means that's the safe
return of the of the receiver and that
means we can use it again tomorrow for
deep ocean live and with me now is
Rihanna
Walton who is one of the scientists on
on this trip Ravana thanks very much for
joining us I should ask you first I
suppose would it be made of the past
hour or so watching this have you seen
it all before
well I mean I've never seen up Deborah
that deep so it's been incredible I know
a diver I know the shallow reefs I know
down to 30 meters but I've never seen
anything that deep here so it's been
incredible experience to witness it you
know live on TV seeing them descending
and seeing the changes in the reef is it
gets much deeper so let's be clear it's
a first broadcasting from that death but
scientists won't have been at that depth
in this area exactly so that because
they asked on its own remote it's so far
from anywhere it's very difficult to do
any research here particularly
underwater so this really this hole at
all is relatively unexplored it's only
the shallow reefs that we've began to
understand in recent years but even much
deeper we still don't know much about it
and coral is your area of expertise
you mean in the Seychelles for sometimes
I know what is your view about the state
of the coral at the moment
so the state of the coral out Deborah is
it's much better than it is in other
areas of Seychelles so unfortunately we
suffered a global bleaching event in
2016 and the the reefs in Seychelles
working quite hard in Ireland suffered a
large high mortality in of coral but how
Deborah did much more resilient so the
corals here to show they're recovering
already and they weren't and they didn't
suffer a high percentage of mortality
like other areas in Seychelles right and
do you think what we find or what you
guys fine here will be a positive story
because there are so many stories of
coral being impacted around the world
how do you think it'll be a positive
story I hope that it will yeah of course
I think we've already seen positive
stories around ever in the past and I
think it it kindly be a positive thing
that were actually you going to explore
and understand the deep air is about
ever now and that's always good for
research
and the question I asked Thomas little
earlier why here why what is so special
about this ecosystem so our demo is very
special because it is so remote it's
suffered far less time to purge any
impacts that anywhere else in this
region so there is fewer effects of
pollution of human involvement so for
that reason it's remained a lot more
resilient it also has a thriving
terrestrial ecosystem which also has
which researchers found that both of
those ecosystems together thrive a
better underwater coral reef system as
well okay and just finally just explain
to us so you will go down you'll get
some of the coral and what will you do
with those samples how will it help you
understand what is happening here yeah
so in the shallows were collecting some
samples of soft corals and hard corals
and also even down to the depths we've
collected samples of soft corals and
that has to get a bit of a catalogue of
the diversity so we're looking for those
common species so we can
understanding of the the composition of
species prompt sort of five meters all
the way down to 200 botting very close
up in her submersible looking very happy
and why not because that is a wonderful
wonderful experience that she has just
gone through and let's have a look ready
very well acquainted with is my pilot
for this mission
Randy holt thank you so much for having
us what an extraordinary working
environment you have it's amazing down
here you know every dive is different
and we get to go places where people
have never been before explain where we
are going to change the cameras which I
can do we've tucked herself into a
crevice isn't 135 meters yeah we're kind
of leaning against the edge of a cliff
an underwater cliff
we were fighting some down drafts and
some up drafts and we got to this
position so we just kind of parked
ourselves on a Ledge and are trying to
stay stationary and I should give you a
proper title of course you are an
Aquanaut if an astronaut explores space
you explore the deep yes you know where
an inner space it's a whole new place
down here and you know it's a 3d
environment so we're always moving
around we're gonna know where we are how
how we're moving through the water
column are we lighter are we duck the
heavier all that that's exactly it's
it's it's amazing to watch should with
all the controls and as you said you're
flying these submersibles you're not
driving them and as you said the oceans
make up 97% of the habitable space on
planet Earth which gives you both a
sense of the depth of the oceans but
also that 3d environment that
we have joined an expedition led by the
scientist of the natural mission their
aim is to perform a deep ocean health
check - map - chart to sample to see
perhaps what no one has ever seen before
and even search for those rarely seen
species literally in the shadows the
dream perhaps of a sixgill shark or even
a Celia camp the Dino fish thought to be
extinct for millions of years and
crucially to see what is happening to
that often colourful coral as it faces
unprecedented threats it is so important
as habitat and home to millions of
species the big question for the
scientists is could the deeper ocean be
a refuge from the dangers of climate
change and even from a plastic pollution
that we have talked so much about at sky
well we are not alone down here this is
someone the red one although it's been
showered by this downdraft
of sediment which you will hear the team
refer to you as Omega out there we can
see them is sub to the yellow the yellow
ah yes the yellow one well we have the
red what I've already done at which they
called Kensington should we see if we
can raise them actually because in there
is the principal scientist on this
amazing expedition dr. Lucy Woodall from
the nectar mission and piloting her sub
is Robert Carmichael let's see if we can
raise them on the ship on the air sir
yeah underwater telephone
Kensington Kensington Omega come back
I'm gonna pass the off day Anna to
interview Lucy talking about
[Music]
[Music]
try again try again
hello Lucy can you hear me
hello Lucy can you hear us I was just
asking you about the reasons you're
trying to explore the deep
[Applause]
Thank You Lucy
that's all I've tried and talk to you a
little bit later thank you well let's go
straight to these pictures we can see
now from the from the remote camera and
it is of the one of the submersibles and
we are expecting them back any moment
now so extraordinary rolling going on
with submerse wasn't a submersibles good
roll but they they certainly can and I'm
joined actually by Professor Louise
Allcock who is with the science mission
here and there's a thing or two about
this what do you make of these pictures
I think you'll probably find it's the
remotely operated vehicle that's rolling
I've never seen this up roll but what do
you make of the picture what we see in
this morning I mean I I think it's
fantastic really we're in somewhere
we've never been before nobody's ever
been here we're looking at a you know a
fantastic new environment
our job is now just to try and work out
exactly what it is down there do a
little bit of systematics check the
species of coral so that we can catalog
it all probably so we've got a lot of
work to do later yes so you will be
going down in these submersibles or your
members will and this is the way that
you can pick up samples that's right one
of the subs is equipped with them a
stereo camera system so that we get
really good video and we've got cameras
in various places actually they're
pointing downwards pointing forwards and
we've got a set on the side as well in
case were in strong currents and we have
to sort of power along a wall and so
we've got one sub totally equipped for
the camera work and the other sub is
equipped with the bio box on the front
and the collecting arm and we have a
permit to collect five specimen to the
earth at each depth that we're working
yes I think that that is Anna's son when
I can we can see her they're preparing
to make return to the to the surface
which probably very pleased about she's
had a wonderful trip I mean it is for
someone like and they're going down like
this for the first time it is just the
most intriguing sort of other world I
think it's an amazing feeling I mean
I've been in plans for almost 30 years
and I had my first submersible time
wagon Alfonzo and it was just incredible
that the sort of feeling of calm sitting
and we were sitting on the bottom at 200
meters and then we just turned the
lights out and all the fish came when it
was just amazing I mean the serene
scientists I just found it
the best thing ever yes and you can't
rush the ascent it's a fairly slow
process isn't it I think everything is
everything is slow you know they don't
go particularly fast the subs we don't
need them to go fast because if we want
good camera pictures we need a very slow
transit so so they work perfectly for
what we're we're trying to get out of
them yes well we expect her back in just
a few moments say a professor or coach
just tell what is your role in all this
so I came on board actually to bring a
bit more experience with them camera
systems and deep water operations so I
mostly work with the deep water ROV off
the coast of Ireland
I've got funding from Science Foundation
Ireland to investigate the corals that
occur in our deep waters we get corals
down to about two and a half thousand
metres which is absolutely fantastic we
work with camera systems you know these
are complicated bits of care trying to
get transit thousands of them in fast
currents a difficult thing to do and any
something that I have a certain amount
of experience in and so I came on board
to try and get get all this working
really and I think we have you know
we've developed protocols now that we're
running with the subs in very fast
currents and we're getting back the
imagery that we need for analysis
we've talked about it a lot but this
place is especially rich obviously as of
a rich ecosystem do you think there will
be new species species that scientists
have found I think it's almost certainly
the case I mean some coral species have
a global distribution and they put out
you know larvae and these travel around
the world in global keratin and there
are some coral species that are really
found all over the world and then there
are other coral species that have very
distinctive distributions often they
even in the same ocean delimited by
death so here 100 meters I get a
different species of coral looks quite
similar but it's this thing so the
chances of us finding new coral species
here I would've 400 percent Aldabra so
remote
something here so quite a proportion of
what's here
Summer Sun will be global species but
and some will be Indian Ocean specific
species but but someone we knew okay
well what we can see is at the bottom in
that submersible and she is on the way
to the surface so as a communication the
receiver that we were using to
communicate is out of the water now so
we can't communicate with you just see
her and the what you can see in the
foreground is the front of the remotely
controlled camera and that is what is
producing these pictures at the moment
and she's about two minutes away from
surfacing here in Aldebaran
so we hear a lot professor about you
know bleaching events and the warm
waters impacting on the coral any sign
so far about
so I haven't lived on the surface Coral
Sea there's a dive team going out this
afternoon to look at surface coral so
really I look so far has been in the
deep water corals and we won't expect to
see such an impact here there's a
thermic line here at about 70 80 meters
just explain what a thermic line is so
thermic line is where the temperature
changes really suddenly so down to about
70 80 meters the temperatures around 28
30 degrees below there it drops steeply
to them
eight degrees and so in that cold water
bleaching is not going to be the same
issue also once you get deep enough of
course these corals they're in really
deep water don't have the symbiotic
algae that the shallow water corals have
so there is some light at the depths
we've been that today in fact the waters
very clear and there's a reasonable
amount of light but as you get down to
250 300 even 500 meters where we're
going there's less light and there
different sorts of corals that wouldn't
suffer completely the same way
[Music]
but you've been in these submersibles
what's it live in it is a very
conservative very tiny other they are
small there they are built for function
non comfort should we say yes they can
get extremely humid in there in fact one
of my jobs that was to empty all the
walls and the condensation from the air
conditioning but even there that the
ignition doesn't really work very well
because they'd like to preserve the the
battery life these this sub pilots so
they they have it warm you get extremely
dehydrated
you can't stretch your legs and that's
something that animal really notice even
though she's apparently they're about
fifty feet from the surface now yep so
they will see a marked increase in the
intensity of light now they'll be able
to see the Sun pouring through the
surface layer perhaps they'll be venting
an awful lot of air from the the
submersible itself and as they rise they
may be going at the same speed of the
bubble which is a very strange feeling
that you are servicing that rapidly and
then that dome will break the surface
and there they will see in that picture
really wonderful pictures aren't they
to see the submersible addressed like
that is quite extraordinary and you can
see the power of the Sun and it is that
Sun that drives the marine ecosystem the
more intense the light the greater the
chance of course the coral making energy
and growing there says apparel for coral
to that the combination light intensity
and warm water can spell coral bleaching
and there we are there is an abortion in
her submersible and well done to the
pilot Randy and I'm sure he's now
communicating with the little rib boat
they've got off this ship which will go
out and pick up Anna after what has been
I mean I have to say just an amazing
experience I'm sure for her she was very
excited this morning certainly when she
knew that this was going to happen
because of course there are lots of
things that can stop these things
happening and have stopped these things
happening for sure and there this the
wave conditions of course have been
quite benign here but the currents have
been the challenge really wherever we
have been in the Seychelles and we are
diving next to these enormous sea bounds
they get very unpredictable very strong
currents and partly because nobody has
mapped the seafloor here in a hundred
years so we have on board a team that is
doing exactly that using much more
up-to-date equipment back in the 1800's
they were throwing ropes over with net
weights at the end trying to gauge the
depth but now they're using sonar and it
is much more accurate and produces quite
exquisite colorful maps very detailed
maps and that will definitely be a
legacy of this mission
well there's detailed notes in there
that are not washing is just putting
away she'll need those again
drink of water earlier and she will have
deserved every bit of that but I have to
say that this is worth still watching
because the very difficult maneuver
about to happen which is our presenter
getting out of that thing and onto a rib
which could be well they were typically
the most entertaining move of the entire
last hour or so but and it's a serious
point so that are the rib has to go out
yes the pilot will stay in the
submersible controlling submersible and
then how what they do is they pick up
and I take out a back the pilot will
eventually get out and then the
submersible will be lifted crane lifted
out of the water is that right it is
indeed so Anna the first thing will
happen is that the hatch there will will
open when the support diver is a sports
swimmer is there on board he'll clamber
on the back of a sub you can see the
Front's are beginning to submerged
slightly below the surface but he'll
clamber on on board he'll open up the
hatch then Anna needs to stretch those
legs that have been crumpled up for the
last few hours stand on her seed stand
on another console and then clamber up
through that hatch and try not to lose
her Bauman's mark as the waves gently
rocked their submersible and then of
course she will make her way down to the
rib that you see there as they're going
off the back of our mothership
lifting off the crane that took back
that ship down that boat down yeah mate
around watch how she does this because
I've got to do it tomorrow
because it's my turn down there tomorrow
and I have to say it is a very exciting
prospect which was a plastic plastic
tomorrow the question impact of plastic
tomorrow and Anna will be on one of
these extraordinary beaches where even
here I mean even here one of the most
inaccessible sanctuaries inaccessible
islands in Indian Ocean very difficult
to even hear plastic tons of it I'm told
is washing up you've been there yes I'm
so getting plastic and I saw wildlife
being trapped in consuming it and that's
the the peril for there we can hear the
the crane just firing up driver going
into his cab and that is the the crane
that will be lifting Anna's submersible
out of the water
thankfully not while she's still on
board there you can see the the rescue
swimmer they're just drying off the the
top of the the hatch because if you open
that with the water still there all that
would pour into the cabin and
the most sensitive electronics that have
kept Hannah and Randy alive I have to
say I never thought that and the botting
exiting a submersible would ever be
alive television event but my suspicion
well it's something isn't it what she's
just done well you can see Randy inside
also doing the same to the rag trying to
dry it off so that she can make a
slightly drier exit that she would have
done otherwise yeah
and my answer had Marcus yeah the longer
they wait in there the hotter that's
getting because there and the other
submersed will be coming up soon and and
they've effectively been down there yes
how does the survey surveying they have
what they call stereoscopy but it's
going to be the transfer from the
submersible to the rib the little
inflatable that comes along son hold on
Anna please they ruin this now
that's quite rough isn't it so the
inflatable will come in and you should
see that any moment so here it is and
now this this little sort of well I said
how would you describe as a little shop
but across or a boat and that so we're
going to stay together and not be
separated by the Indian in the nations
well you see the driver of the boat
they're struggling to get the right
position yeah
is struggling over this a little bit so
what do they do if just tossed out the
magnet she's not he's got a little bit
there
Marine grabs the boat tenable at the TV
sideshow this moment
[Music]
whew she's done it give us a wave and I
forget to say
no idea she's on live television but
there we are so she is away she'll be
brought back now to the ship and the
pilot
pilot will also exit exit now but these
submersibles used as we saw during that
previous hour for a very serious point
they have these robotic arms they take
the samples you put the samples in the
submersibles and bring them up here for
the scientists that we be talking to to
start with you yes because they're
looking for new species and the only way
of doing that has been to the surface
where they can actually do some analysis
they can catalog those species of coral
for the miniature of the Seychelles but
also they have lots of cameras onboard
their submersibles at some point afford
something down they have what they call
stereoscopic cameras as I was about to
tell you before and those are 3d cameras
where they can try and understand the
structure of the rebreather of the
complexity of that reef there's an awful
lot of science that he's done as these
subs travel on mother called transects
marked distances along the reef where
they will be counting life and also that
the
different species of life and that
really is the kind of work that they'll
be doing now and there you can see that
they're beginning to prepare the
submersible for it to be lifted out by
the crane Randy the pilot is still on
board you can see him turning on his
thrusters there at the back trying to
bring the submersible within range of
the crane and there you see emerging
there the the bottom the hook that Shane
will then clip-ons those the ropes that
he's holding there above the glass dome
of the submersible
and in your top left is on their way
back and I can't work out Randy is going
to go on the that rib as well Thomas
just for now thanks very much let's
bring in our next guest talking there
with Thomas about mapping and surveying
the deep and that's what you specialized
in that's what you do isn't it so yeah
that's what we've been doing on on this
FRC we've been hold on hold on if I see
what it's done for fast rescue craft so
it's normally used for my overboard
situations but we've fitted out with all
our server equipment so when we get to a
location we go out first we survey the
areas as Thomas just said before a lot
these areas so it's a big it's really a
bigger version of the inflatable that
we're seeing yeah exactly exactly that
it's just a version of that and we're
going out and finding a good area in a
safe area for the substitue down yeah
and your Ana mapping the the
how deep the knew about some of the
system we've got here that we've
Teledyne marine of given to us we've we
compact down to about 600 700 meters so
we're going from about about 600 meters
all the way into about 4 or 5 meters so
they're going basically as far offshore
as we can get
obviously the subs and can only go to
300 meters and the rav goes down to 500
so you can see it all on computer here
comes her Randy who was down there with
there and with an opposing very
experienced two submersible pilot
10 years an American guy who's leaner
and actually put this submersible
together for this trip he takes it apart
and then rebuilds it so he certainly
knows what he's highlighting and
certainly knows about what he's doing
and now the rig will bring Anna who has
hard hat battle back on bringing out and
Randy background to the ship and
hopefully we'll be able to to see them
reasonably soon yes are going back to
actually now there is the submersible no
that is being lifted
[Music]
back onto me
behind us there
extraordinary mr. Kephart is a very
fantastic have you been there anyone I
haven't I've been out every day
surveying yes hopefully get a chance to
or at the end well look as we watch
these pictures of the submersible coming
back we were just saying so you have a
computer all yes so you can watch what
you're yes oh we see the 3d map of the
seabed being generated in real time as
we're going along that all generates on
the computer and then once were finished
we come back on board and we show that
to the sub pilots and the ROV pilots and
then from that informs where they're
going to do their dives obviously the
areas are looking for these things steep
walls and they've been on today so yeah
we were out yesterday surveying that
find out where it is so we can get the
ship in the right position and find some
good areas into their science
I hope they treat this submersible
carefully because that's that's what I'm
getting to honey this tomorrow so they
don't come back thing down but they've
got pretty good at it by now they have
got pretty good at it by now yeah I'm
sure
okay well Mike thanks very much indeed
thanks very much and Thomas is back with
us
Thomas they'll be here a lot longer than
we will
how long do these missions last and you
know what will they do with the
information they get well they're away
for about seven weeks they'll be going
on from algebra to other islands outer
islands here at Seychelles again more
sea mounts on these underwater mountains
and they're trying to understand they're
trying to produce a catalogue of life
which is so important the Seychelles
government has been ahead of the curve
on marine protection that they really
get it they have already protected 15%
of their vast ocean territory that's the
size of the UK and they're going to
protect another 15% so doubling it by
2020 but what they need to know is what
do you protect what is so special what
is so rare here in Aldabra
to make sure that it is not destroyed by
human activity from further afield
whether that be climate change or
pollution plastic pollution were indeed
overfishing these are the issues that
can affect these waters and that is why
they're desperate to protect the life
within
two big coral events fairly recently was
in 2000 1998 9:30 in the 2009 2 4 3 2016
as well and what impact with those being
each bleaching event data called on
there boy impact would they have had
here and would the call and being able
to resist that here so they did affect
coral here but interestingly the the
coral here in algebra seems to have been
more robust although an awful lot of it
did bleach that's when it spits out is
algae because it can't tolerate the hot
water and it just shuts down in effect a
bit like when we have a fever we don't
feel like eating well the same is true
of the coral too so it spits out his
food source the algae but what happened
elsewhere in the Seychelles is that the
warm water persisted and the coral died
but here because it's in a marine
protected area because there are many
more fish feeding all the algae that
would otherwise have smothered the reef
that coral had a much better chance of
recovery so it really has bounced back
and that is why you see such abundant
marine life here and is this general
warming will localized warming or both
that's a really good question it is
general so every year in the summer of
course you would get spikes in
temperature here in the water but what
is happening now is that the background
you like with climate change is
increasing so it's coming from a lower
trough and the peaks are getting higher
each summer and it's that summer peak
which is getting a much higher and at
the time and much longer and that's
what's causing the coal much more
problem many more problems and
particularly in an El Nino year that's
that current of the South Africa South
American which doubles up with climate
change she'll be back on board which
will be very good news after well quite
a broadcasting experience for and well
for everyone quite a broadcasting
experience when they work we'll have
seen that live for a while I have to say
I was a bit of a skeptic I thought well
they'll be cutting back to us because
the thing it was there wasn't it and we
saw those pictures and and Anna did
remarkably well and
and there is oliver steeds all of us t2
is the head of the mission and he will
welcome Anna back to the to the ship and
and I have to say I was talking to her
over breakfast this morning is she well
she was saying last night that she
wasn't nervous and then this morning she
admitted that it was all getting a bit
tense and then we she was about to get
in the submarine there was a storm in
the distance and all those things go
through one's mind and there's a
broadcaster you know you don't do these
things very often than they are they're
exceptionally interesting and we're
exceptionally privileged to do this but
they are not challenging nevertheless
and not something everybody would want
to do let's be honest about it and
but she's back and
and we're very happy about this I'm
standing now with Paris Stefan artists
who is one of the scientists at Paris
the reasons I've just got you in here is
because you have done this already
haven't you beat down and you had a look
and what did you make of the experience
first of all I would like to say it's
been an amazing privilege and X or e
privilege to be able to dive in algebra
yesterday was my first dive in a
submersible it was an amazing experience
we went to about having 10 meters deep
and we saw a lot of healthy-looking
ecosystems rich with soft corals and
fish so far it looks very good and I
hope we will find the same results and
shallow and deeper reefs yeah you say it
so far looks very good it all looks
pretty healthy
it all looks pretty healthy no signs of
coal disease those times of plastic
pollution in the depth we serve it
yesterday and fish seem to be abundant
with so many different species of sharks
manta rays and so I think so
[Music]
amazing amazing even coming to the
surface is amazing
because you're coming through surrounded
by bubbles and they're getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger next
thing you know it's like you think
you're getting rocked up and down and
you pop out in the bright sunlight and
you see the ship here and it still
washing them down and you feel like you
feel like from the depths up to the
light and you feel that contrast yes
all of it all of it usually different
all the way through is right now I know
coming up is you know what are the best
bits I'm just sounds really strange I
mean going down as well cos you did it
right eat it right down made that first
of all and go down quite suddenly even
then and then you drop through blue and
it's just blue and you and I wasn't
waiting to see fish straightaway but
it's blue and you until you hit the
bottom which is my sandy yeah and then
we are riding deeper parts and rocky out
and little communities to see SI phan
small fish Hooper's gonna shock said
clay bar
from quite early on the shop didn't want
to seem too
but they go to investigate who we are
what we are they've never seen us before
and we drop down to
[Music]
175 metres we'll say well we thought
that's what we thought with music yes
but we can be heard
just about but we kept communication yes
exactly exactly
I mean you see they put this plate down
but with lights on there too to be right
there so we can look up and see that
quite clearly and it's not that the fish
seem to my catcher of seven windows yeah
there's a shark checking that out as
well
how did she believe that me because of
is she nervous
oh let's just work with yeah so I mean
it's always exciting and then we did a
dive yesterday but today was was the new
is a new spy new environment yeah well
then he was worrying me because we went
down quite early today and I and he
began to talk about us running out of
mushrooms before we actually go on it
said that Devorah me so we parked our
selves up as best as best we can in a
rocky I've got the grabber arm out to
hold up in Soraka state
Lucy will emerge with samples and she's
been doing serious science down there
and we'll be using that for even the
cameras to see the enemies perhaps to
see the coral and all of that's being
reported and then that will all go into
a database and properly analyzed so the
science is going on even with the
cameras on I'm sure we can laser there's
a highlight especially when you can see
the other sunrise
when it's lights on up against this
really craggy stable
that's when it feels otherworldly and
you you see what you must look like
because you're just in this lovely
pollen from 270 degrees sphere Plus begs
me to see so much and then you see what
you must look like when you see themself
you still get this bug like aliens over
30 seconds left on the program your
highlight what was the best moment here
[Music]
that one always a shot we had 30 seconds
we've now got 20 second always the shark
and oddly the journey I tell you what it
was I think it was right at the
beginning well here we are
it was lovely and it was broadcasting
first in so many ways and it was a
wonderful job very well done and you can
see all the highlights on the sky
tonight we're back tomorrow 8 o'clock
Chinese style antics Sky News calm and
that is it
in the Indonesian
[Music]